hello everyone Karen warden with film
courage the radio show happy holidays by
the way we're here with the wonderful
david spade's we just finished our radio
interview and the youtube sensation
writer actor comedian and we talked a
little bit about you know how you did
have a few down times where you had to
rebuild your youtube page and there were
you know some haters that do come out
and post comments and you've risen above
that and i think what's fascinating is
that the youtube community is so
collaborative and they're very inclusive
of one another can you talk about that
yes I could oh I found especially like
what I had to start all over from
scratch know when the channel went down
as I began to get new fans and they kind
of like a eventually heard about what
happened cuz you know eventually you
know some of my old fans found me but
like a very small percentage so um it's
now I'm basically like holiday what
happened to your old channel and blah
blah blah know that I got everybody else
curious when he had another channel and
so as the story you know kind of kind of
floated around YouTube not think a lot
of them kind of help you know no they
pull together and really started like
spreading my videos out a lot no
tweeting them on you know Twitter no
Facebook whatnot and really help me help
me gain you know a larger audience you
know actually been what I had before so
even though I'm missing a large
percentage of my old audience because
there's a whole different name you know
my name is not you know plastered all
over like it used to be um like within a
year you know I've got like 160 you know
thousand you know subscriber so you know
it's kind of cool to see them you know
pull together to you know kind of help
me like that so yeah it kind of feels
good the tears here I'm curious too
how do you feel about people who think
that YouTube is not really the way of
the future I know I heard an interview
with Hollywood super agent Ari Emanuel
and I think the one of the characters on
entourage is based on and he did an
interview for the web two point O summit
he said he doesn't really see internet
stars having the same poll even in this
new age of a video on demand and
everything as the traditional studio you
know actors people that are represented
by CAA UTA how do you respond to that um
I'd have to say she um right now no I
have to agree with them only because
there are so many people on YouTube and
a lot not all but a lot of the people
that have large numbers whatnot it they
really don't have the type of material
that people used to seeing in movies or
television you know you could have a
dude with 300,000 fans and like I said
you go to his page and he's doing videos
like it you know so it's hard for
Hollywood anybody else to take it
serious Vic the internet seriously um
but there are extremely talented people
on YouTube that don't have those numbers
yet and I think as time goes by no
they're really going to start pulling in
you know that audience and it's going to
it's going to translate it's gonna have
to be a real merger between the two and
I see that from a person like myself who
is an actor first and then got into the
internet only to build up a name to go
back with my acting I see that so it's
not like I'm a internet person that's
like oh I'm gonna do this and get big on
the internet you know so I can become an
actor you know it's reversed for me so I
see so I know both sides and I think in
time you know especially with the
quality that you can do on YouTube now
and everybody everybody can edit their
own stuff they can buy decent equipment
and it looks better than television you
know it will happen you know in time but
uh the very near future
no but you can already see the hit that
it's having you know in the movie
industry and you know as far as movies
dvds like people look for the stuff on
the internet now you know so it's
already having an impact but it would
definitely stronger in years to come